why is it that the American people
pretty much don't care about the
political status of most countries
outside the United States including
Ukraine but on Capitol Hill the
Democrats are completely head over heels
for Ukraine they all change their little
you their Twitter and Facebook bios to
include the Ukrainian flag for some
reason absurd by the way you're an
American you should have the American
flag in your bio not the not the flag of
any other foreign Nation no matter how
sympathetic we might be with that Nation
but but a lot of Republicans do though
the whole Republican establishment is
Gaga over Ukraine Mitch McConnell Senate
majority Senate minority leader leader
of the Republicans in the Senate has
said that the top priority for
republicans is Ukraine making sure the
defense department can deal with the
major threats coming from Russia and
China
providing assistance for
the ukrainians to defeat the Russians
that's the number one priority for the
United States right now
according to most Republicans that's
sort of how we see the
challenges confronting the country at
the moment
that's the that's the top issue
according to Mr cocaine himself so what
does this show
what it shows is not just that those
guys on Capitol Hill are totally crazy
there are a lot of things but they're
not totally crazy they usually have a
reason for doing what they're doing they
are very rational actors politicians in
both parties inasmuch as they're very
very good at keeping themselves in power
they have a a an uncanny ability for
cold calculation so what is the
calculation here on Ukraine
I think it shows you what a lot of
people have suspected from the beginning
which is that all this talk about the
independence and sovereignty of Ukraine
that's a bunch of nonsense Ukraine is a
border state a border Nation it has been
one for a long time it is a Battleground
for for fights between the East and the
West between Russia and Europe and the
United States and the reason that this
war broke out in the first place
is because in Ukraine 10 years ago you
had a pro-russian leader and the U.S
didn't like that very much and so
Western Powers put pressure on Ukraine
and helped to to fund and encourage
discontent in Ukraine that did already
exist to that that ultimately led to the
maidon Revolution and ousted the
pro-russian leader and put in a more Pro
wet pro-russian leader as did that guy
it's very confusing when you're talking
about Ukraine
the maidon revolution then led to a more
pro-western government in Ukraine then
you started seeing a lot of talk about
Ukraine joining the European Union
Ukraine joining NATO Russia said that
that would be an unacceptable security
risk to have NATO come that close to its
borders and that important the country
and so then you saw you saw Russia Annex
parts of Ukraine this is going back now
eight years and then you saw uh the
major war breakout earlier this year in
Ukraine and what this tells me is
Ukraine is not viewed as an independent
nation obviously by Russia or by the
United States and Europe Ukraine is
being viewed right now
as a theater of Empire
Russia says it openly
the U.S and the West
say it implicitly
when we say that Ukraine is the most
important issue for Americans what we're
saying is that the American Western
Empire is very important the American
World Order where we are the top dog and
we are we are governing the rules of the
world is very very important and I'm not
even disputing that that is the current
world order that we have and they're
saying we cannot allow Russia to
encroach on Ukraine why not because
Ukraine is this absolutely Sovereign
independent nation because
Ukraine is a part of the broader
Imperial project for
the US and the west and we all know that
to be the case I'm not even knocking it
I'm not attacking that I I'd rather we
run the world than the Russians run the
world or China run the world but that's
what it is it is an Imperial Battle we
like to think that we're living in the
new modern times we're so different from
all those terrible Old State actors in
the past remember when they fought Wars
of Empire and land Conquest we're doing
the exact same now because that's that's
a fact of politics that is just how
people interact in the world and that
that's what we're seeing that's what
that's what Mitch McConnell means when
he says it's the most important thing
it's the most important thing to what
the American Nation I don't think so I
think it's the most important thing to
the American Empire now Rand Paul would
disagree Rand Paul who is much more
interested in pulling back American
influence abroad and focusing in on the
problems that we've got here at home he
he asked the question where do the real
threats to America lie
I brought with me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released but what's the clamor the
clamor's devote vote now let's get it
done why are you standing in the way of
spending
well the real question is this what is
more dangerous are we at risk for being
invaded by a foreign power if we don't
put 45 billion into the military Are we
more at risk by adding to a 31 trillion
dollar debt
I think the greatest risk to our
national security is our debt the
American people don't want this they're
sick and tired of it they're paying for
it through the nose with inflation
adding a trillion dollars to the deficit
will simply fuel the fires that are
consuming our wages and consuming our
retirement plans it's a terrible system
someone needs to stand up we're standing
up and we're going to say no
preach pre-trend
what's amazing about rand's statement
here is that
he actually I believe got the number
wrong on military spending
he referred to the 45 billion dollar
number instead of the 76 billion dollar
number I think he confused the Boost to
American military spending with the
Boost to Ukraine spending and it's not a
knock on him one it's very confusing and
the reports are a little bit ambiguous
and it shows you the heart of the
problem which is that
the dams dropped this 4 000 plus page
Bill and they say okay you got to vote
on it in three days
where even a United States Senator
doesn't get a chance to vote on that and
when you look at the Boost of military
spending you had boost to military
spending for our country boost military
spending for other countries and they
say without this without the 76 billion
extra dollars that we get an American
military spending that country is going
to be an existential risk I don't know I
think Rand Paul is right I think that
our debt
poses a far larger long-term risk than
some marginal increase in defense
spending I remember 10 years ago Mitch
Daniels then the governor of Indiana a
lot of people thought he was going to
run for president he said we're facing a
new Red Menace this time it's not the
commies it's not the Soviets exactly
it's the debt it's a Red Menace
consisting of ink
if we manage our own country in such an
irresponsible way that we we become more
and more dependent on China to pay for
all of our Flights of Fancy and we open
up our borders and we allow domestic
Discord to tear our country apart then
Russia is going to be the least of our
worries guys we've got a lot more
problems a lot closer to home we've also
got
a magician coming up on the member block
right now a magician who pulled off one
of the most impressive magic tricks of
the year go check it out if you're not a
member
you got to join click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]